over 1.5 million American troops were
deployed to Iraq and Afghanistan from
2001 to 2011 many returned with visible
scars of war but for some their injury
is hidden at some of the military bases
throughout those regions waste materials
were disposed of in so-called burn pits
breathing fumes from those fires appears
to have damaged the health of countless
veterans Barry Peterson has their story
dan Gentek struggles with what most of
us don't even think about taking her
breath an Army veteran he's part of a
lung study at National Jewish Hospital
in Denver but he's also part of
something much larger he was one of
thousands of men and women who served in
Iraq and Afghanistan and may be sick or
dying because this was the air they had
to breathe smoke from massive burn pits
next to their bases what does the smell
look kind of like when you burn plastic
you get that acrid smell depending on
how strong the winds are and the smoke
could be pretty strong so you just
constantly either saw the smoke or smelt
it pretty much every day all day all day
all night all day all night yes bring
our stuff in yes into the burn pits when
things like batteries chemicals heavy
metals arsenic a report by a Special
Inspector General put it bluntly it is
indefensible that US military personnel
who were already at risk of serious
injury and death when fighting the enemy
were put at further risk from the
potentially harmful emissions from the
use of open air burn pits even worse the
report detailed millions spent on
incinerators to properly dispose of
waste but many sat idle next to the
active burn pits Dan was deployed at
Balad Air Base in Iraq where an Air
Force expert issued a warning about the
burn pits there and added it is amazing
that this burn pit has been able to
operate without restrictions over the
past few years I think at the end of the
day you know the data look good in terms
of your one function it hasn't gotten
better but it hasn't gotten worse dr.
Cecile Rose is a
pulmonologist an occupational medicine
doctor who is principal investigator of
the five-year long study funded by the
Department of Defense
I think our study is really designed to
understand what the spectrum of lung
diseases are that can occur following
these in elation elation theater and
then that's called breathing when you're
that's right
she has already seen some results we
have described a spectrum of diseases
that are related to deployment they
weren't there before and they are
clearly there after people have returned
from these arid and extreme environments
but it's not as simple as poison to a
plume of toxic smoke and those potential
hazards include things like desert dusts
very intense sandstorms a huge amount of
diesel exhaust and diesel particulate
paints that may cause lung disease in
just the course of their regular job
duties dan is not alone the Veterans
Administration set up a voluntary burn
pit registry more than a hundred eighty
thousand have signed up but of the
12,000 filed claims to the VA connected
to burn pits only about 2500 have been
accepted and a victim's lawsuit against
contractors who oversaw some of the pits
was rejected by the Supreme Court one of
the denied VA claims was Jennifer Kepner
who believed her fatal pancreatic cancer
was caused by burn pit exposure in Iraq
is there severe enough consequences
asked the family of Jennifer Kepner who
died from pancreatic cancer her
congressman Raul Ruiz from California
got her family survivor benefits but he
didn't stop there
a harvard-trained emergency room doctor
he has launched a legislative blitz to
get sick veterans benefits now and not
wait four more years and more studies
there is enough there's enough to act on
it when people are exposed to an illness
and they come in dying on a gurney in
the emergency department you don't have
to wait and and for that pristine
science to determine that this
is sick and they're dying in you need to
act on it and take care of the veteran
the patient that should be our common
sense approach when you put veterans in
the center of the VA system
Ruiz sees a parallel in American history
the use of Agent Orange in the Vietnam
War
it's a powerful herbicide spread widely
to kill jungle foliage veterans who were
exposed and got six years after fought
the VA for benefits a battle that took
decades to win be accountable being
responsible do what's right for our
veterans give them the care that they
need and if they don't then they should
be held accountable I don't know if they
will be I don't know how long people
will live how long will they survived
well that's like the VA accountable well
that's my concern
we cannot let burn pit exposure veterans
be the Vietnam veterans exposed to Agent
Orange of our generations we can't do
that in April the US Central Command
reported nine burn pits creating toxic
smoke but says 13 burn pits at the
moment are burning non hazardous waste
they also say they could change at any
time if battlefields conditions change a
Department of Defense spokeswoman added
we are concerned that toxins from burn
pit emissions may pose health risks and
we are assessing potential long-term
impacts a skeptical ruies worries that
newly deployed soldiers are still at
risk is this still going on it's still
going on it's still going on and when
you think that the military is willing
to expose men and women our young sons
and daughters and brothers and sisters
to burn pits simply because they say it
is inconvenient and not cost-effective
for them it's shameful it's shameful so
in the years ahead there may be even
more like Dan no longer a father who can
go on a hike with his kids I used to be
very active dirt bike riding mountain
bike riding hiking with the family very
active with my kids now I don't do any
of the
don't or can't can't for CBS this
morning Saturday Barry Petersen Denver
we're in existence and it doesn't seem
that much further down a line than what
we saw in 2001 down at Ground Zero and
all of the people now suffering the
first responders the rescuers the people
working to rebuild down there this
should not be this an interesting
parallel is the story I've been covering
for a long time here at CBS News of some
of the great producers here in varying
ways of different people impacted around
the country by burn pits but it makes
sense when you're burning chemicals
weapons of war plastics other things it
goes it goes into the air and then it
goes somewhere the question is when
you're going to make it right I thought
the one word that they use in the report
indefensible one of the more important
ones there